all right Hollywood Hollywood where' you
grow up where are you from originally I
grew up in South Central tell me about
your family nine kids pretty traditional
Mexican family I was the first to uh
make it to major university and the
first one to become addicted and the
first one to pick up some
felonies how did you end up on that
path I had an older brother that uh as a
kid I followed him around you can say I
learned all my bad habits from him and
uh when everyone else had abandoned him
to his addiction I was driving around
South Central to all the different
motels looking for them and uh then one
day I was on my way to a club so I was
pretty drunk and I wanted to see what
was all about and I took a blast and
that's when my life as an addict became
began and I've been getting high ever
since what was your
drug cocaine free
base
then
uh after about a 5e stint with cocaine I
stopped for about 10 years then I
started again when I moved out to
Philadelphia and then uh from there I
moved to
Miami which got pretty crazy CU Miami's
even you know almost everything's legal
in Miami then I came back and uh I
started using crystal meth because I
thought I could function better with it
and after a few years about five years
after pretty much losing everything I
had worked
for I thought I'd get off it so I
started to smoke cocaine cuz they say
sometimes if you do one drug it breaks
you off another that's right and it
worked for the most part except now I'm
stuck smoking cocaine correct yes
yeah what's a harder addiction to deal
with crystal meth or
crack I think uh crystal meth has the
advant Vantage of you being able to
function on it so the disadvantage is
you'll do it a lot longer because you
can go and detect it sometimes crack
cocaine it hits you pretty at least me
right you can get paranoid you know it's
more expensive that's when you run
around selling everything you have you
know some people resort to stealing I
never did but it's definitely a better
High impossible to keep a job it's
pretty hard I mean
I consider crack cocaine a real drug
crystal meth it's like weed or alcohol I
mean I really don't understand how
anybody could be out here just on that
crack cocaine heroin fentanyl those are
real
drugs you have kids no no kids no kids
how old are you 55 55 you look good for
55 thank you I guess that's part of you
know being Undercover
what does your family think of your Life
Path they pretty much broke all
associations with me my dad including my
father so
uh I was out here pretty much for a few
maybe two months just um living in the
car or occasionally sleeping in a
tent uh I ended up wrecking two cars
while I was out here and ruining a third
and the brother who initially
exposed me to to hard drugs open this
door for me I didn't ask him to but he
insisted so I went over there and U for
about six weeks I think I did pretty
good but obviously I'm back here now you
guys have a special
connection yeah I mean he he won't tell
the family if I you know if I have a
relapse is he still
using he still uses you know he's I
guess what they call a chronic relapser
whatever that whatever that means but um
you know as far as I'm concerned you
either use or you don't right now are
you homeless now uh well this is my last
week with him so I will be as of uh
Sunday Sunday
night and so I got to right now I'm
trying to make some money to get a a car
so I can live in there you look pretty
put together for a guy who's homeless
well I have a bachelor's and a master's
degree I've been pretty successful in uh
the industry that that I've been a part
of you know I consider myself a master
salesman
and it's part of my appeal what kind of
jobs have you
had sales marketing uh
working um different Industries but you
know that's getting somebody to sign on
the dotted line that's that's my
specialty what's your biggest
[Music]
regret I don't know if I have any
regrets I think that there's a lot of
beauty out here I mean I fell in love
out
here if you ever want to self annihilate
Fall in Love on skid
R because it's pretty impossible tell me
about that you met a girl uh yeah I met
several girls out here I think all of
them are beautiful intelligent unique I
mean Brave bold creative but this one
you know was different to me and she
inspired me to write you know writing is
what I do and if a woman can inspire me
to write then that's about as special as
a
gets is there something about broken
birds that appeals to
you maybe you know uh you know you know
I know the expression you know Captain
sa a hope I mean I don't know if that's
me but there is something about
individuals who I think have incredible
potential that aren't realizing it
that deserve some extra
support you know
um they don't ask for it right no one's
ever asked me for any extra support or
any help um so I don't feel like as if
anyone's obligated to me for anything
because it's you know I I give it freely
and um I think they appreciate it but
who knows I mean I've seen people who
are whose
Partners have ADD problems and they're
lost and everyone's just saying just
dump her just get rid of her and then
miraculously somehow she gets
clean and the guy dumps the
girl because he wants a broken
Bird yeah I don't think I do I mean I've
been out here for a few years now you
know off and on I mean this is the only
social life I have is right here on skid
R and uh but I think uh for broken bird
you know wanted to fly again I would
take off with it emotionally what do you
go through living this
life it's easy to ask
why you know it's it's easy to get down
at times and wonder you
know what could have been or or the
consequences of of my actions and I mean
obviously
um I lost quite a bit being out here and
uh definitely the respect of all my
family and
friends and
um so you know depending on on my mood
that can matter quite a bit I could feel
you know
devastated
but sometimes I don't sometimes I feel
empowered by being out here by
associating with people that I think um
have a lot to offer and you
know I think I personally think that
skro
is a place of incredibly untapped
potential I think this could be one of
the most successful communities in
Southern California there's not much
talent and intellect out
here a lot of these people have a hard
time applying that Talent though making
it yeah I
mean I agree my I guess if you say I
have a dream right would be to open up
some sort of business like on the floor
above this room and anybody who wants to
work
you know and uh you'll have a short line
H here's one thing I believe I believe
that many people out
here
would kick their habit if they had the
kind of support required and the rehab
home isn't going to cut it and neither
is whatever you get from gr they would
need some it would take some Deep
Pockets yeah because they would have to
be able
to first off use to their heart's
content until so they realize that
they're missing out on a lot that is
being offered and then who knows maybe
pick up an addiction like hot like
shopping or something and then you know
just stay busy because if you stay busy
then you start realizing that hey I
didn't have to get high all day I did
get high for half the day or you know uh
when night hit but you start to accept
that you can have a different kind of
life just to give you an idea this
individual you know like many who smoke
fetty right start nodding
off used to knot off every day right and
then one week I was like you realize you
haven't knoted off in days and they were
like wow you're right because we were
busy doing things so I know that that
could have that could have increased and
that could have evolved into something
give them some Mission something yeah at
the end of the day I guess we were in a
good match I don't think it had anything
anything to do with her not being uh not
willing to uh to kick a habit the
problem is also very often the childhood
there's traumas that they're carrying
with them that aren't just in a race yes
I mean by getting a job I certainly have
childhood trauma I mean you know I
didn't realize that till recently
but um what did you
realize that some of the things that
happened to me as a child have stayed
with me I mean that's why I have a a big
problem with
commitment um that's why I mean you
won't find too many people my age with
my background that is not married and do
not have children I mean is pretty
pretty shocking actually um most people
don't believe it but it's the truth and
the truth is I mean I was married for
two or three years and just that fear of
commitment kept me away from from U
father a child in the back of my in my
mind I knew I didn't want to be in that
relationship so I know that sounds kind
of tragic and kind of you
know maybe even mean
but but I I just I just follow my heart
and I have a feeling that there's a
woman out there that I'll fall in love
with and want a baby with her first day
I metet her so I'll keep looking
actually not really looking but I'm open
to you're open to it no what's your
biggest fear
now not fulfilling my potential and in
my opinion that
includes incorporating this experience
out here I think uh I believe everything
happens for a reason I believe that I'm
a better person by my experience out
here I was you know I was I'm a cradle
Catholic I tried you know at different
times
living a spiritual life but there are
always barriers in embracing all of
society but after my experience out here
I don't see any difference between
anyone sleeping in a tent or on the
floor and somebody living in a highrise
so I think it makes me a better Catholic
so I'm trying to get back on that path
now and I feel a lot more equipped I
feel uh more spiritually
enlightened what would you say is your
greatest
strength my communication skills and I'm
I could be pretty
Charming you're a Salesman I'm a
Salesman what's been your lowest point
in your
life probably being in jail it's a
pretty messed up place to be you know
you're having your freedom taken away
from
you pretty maddening if you ask me you
can't do anything literally at the mercy
of the state you know as long as as I'm
out here I'm free to exercise my will do
whatever I want I can stay here or leave
there's the possibility of spending more
time in jail for something you did keep
you walking a straight your path no I'm
pretty good about avoiding scenarios
where I think I might get
arrested so I have to be careful about
who I hang out with because some people
are pretty uh Reckless and don't care
but I have to worry about that because I
still have one foot so to speak in in
the professional world I guess you could
say or the conservative World Square
world yeah normies right and if I were
to get pop for for something like you
know being out here I stand to lose
everything and I can't afford that where
would you like to be in five
years I don't know maybe occupy the
whole floor and some building and here
down in skid row and you know have make
it a luxury suite and have the doors
open to anybody who wants to come in who
wants to make
money and if they want interesting idea
yeah I I think if take I think it would
be awesome I think that there's a lot of
people out there who would contribute
who would help who would be excited
about something like this yeah there's a
few that would actually go for it I'm
sorry there's a few people that would
actually benefit from that yeah
absolutely there's a lot that would just
avoid it I mean bottom line is this
anybody out here using needs to be the
needs to get the equivalent of a job
making like 50 60,000 year if they don't
get that forget it something giving them
24,000 year is not going to cut it
they're going to end up getting high
they got to make more money than they've
ever made and want to keep it and the
cost of living is so high especially
here in LA and I I see what people are
going through and what they're dealing
with and and the hustles that
they're doing you know I see how
the the cost of living which is
great is a huge factor in all of these
problems it's just impossible to keep a
roof over your head or to keep food on
the table so people will take to these
hustles that'll put them in trouble lead
lead to drug use all that stuff I think
what I think what most people out here
are looking for is really an
opportunity less than support an
opportunity because support is limited
and support often comes with a lot of
rules and regulations and um you know um
you lose some of your freedom
and it's not really an opportunity it's
just support so this would be you know
opportunity means that they can you know
rise as as you know as high as possible
and um I mean this is America right and
there's so
much there's so many ways to make money
there's so many ways to to thrive in
this society and um and I think that
if uh yeah I mean I just think that that
there is the possibility for someone to
step forward and do something that can
transform that can be transformative
that's the word support doesn't
transform you an opportunity can
transform you it's a great
point you just got to deal with that
cost of living issue it'll be like uh
paros noos you know that spot over there
which one paros by the guy who ran for
mayor oh right I've seen it it'll be
like a p is for
adults par
or adct I don't know what would you
say is the uh most important lesson
you've learned in your life
Hollywood two lessons I learned and this
girl taught them to me the first one is
not to compare myself to
anybody I realized how wrong that is
now and the second one
is
never
to never never to justest at someone's
expense you know I always thought I was
pretty
witty and then I realized that almost
every joke I made was at someone's
expense it was just it was witty maybe
there was no F language but at the end
of the day I was belittling someone and
I realized all it was was the the
talking I learned growing up you know in
the
streets you know morphed into some sort
of into educated lines but it was the
same BS I was you know just making fun
of somebody so I don't do that no more
so I probably won't make too many people
laugh
anymore but I feel bad about it all
right Hollywood thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
lots of luck from hereo
peace